(applaudissements)
à la Clinique 180 de Montréal.
Après des années d'efforts,
le travail de l'équipe
multidisciplinaire spécialisée
dans le traitement de l'obés
par un don corporatif
de 2 millions de dollars.
BENOIT TOUSIGNANT, resp. Aff.
externes, Novo Nordisk Canada
- C'est vraiment un super beau
projet qui est porteur pour
les patients qui vivent avec
d'avoir une bonne éducation pour
les professionnels de la santé.
- La somme servira à mettre
sur pied la première formation
de niveau universitairelelelelee
de l'obésité.
Médecins, pharmaciens,
d'ici trois ans, un grand nombre
de professionnels pourront
la recevoir.
fondatrice de l'Approche 180
- On sait qu'il y a 50 % denos ,
pas juste ici au Québec,
mais partout dans le monde, qui
à l'égard de cette maladie-là.
50 % d'entre eux rapportent
ne pas avoir eu de formation.
de la Dre St-Pierre, qui compte
trois cliniques, est intervenue
auprès de plusieurs milliers
de patients.
- C'est pas pour rien que l'OMS
fait des recommandations pour
qu'on soit capable d'av==ñ
une approche comme celle-là,
c'est 94 % de résultats positifs
de la maladie, une amélioration
du mieux-être et de la santé
globale de l'enfant.
- Marième souffrait
d'un problème de surpoids
et d'un problème d'anxiété
à la clinique en 2019.
- J'étai- J'étai- J'étai- J'étap
renfermé sur moi-même,je parlai,
j'étais gênée, je gardais
mon anxiété pour moi.
santé mentale, suivi médical,
la jeune fille, mais également
sa famille ont été intégrées
au plan de traitement.
- Marième a été capable
d'être outillée et d'avoir
des stratégies pour intervenird.
- Trois ans plus tard, elle va
beaucoupbeaucoupbeaucoupbeaucout
d'être infirmière vient
tout juste d'être acceptée
- Aujourd'hui, après toutès tout
ce cheminement-là, je suis
une fille super positive,
souriantun bon
cheminement pour continuer
comme ça.....
- On estime que le tiers
des jeunes Canadiens et, au
total, plus de 500 000 millions
de jeunes dans le
de surpoids ou d'obésité.
Radio-Canada, Mon